tell me about that transition to Chicago
because that's quite a leap it is a
great City I love it and I used to I had
three jobs I was I was a dishwasher at
the Grand Lux Cafe on Michigan Avenue
and I was doing open mics at night and I
was a security guard at a tiny school
and it was
I'd venture to say one of the best times
in my life you know where you're
for some reason you're broke as hell but
you always have enough money for booze
and a pack of cigarettes you know at
that age yeah it somehow shows up and
you have enough money for that one date
that you want to have and there's
kind of nothing to lose you know is a
great year of my life and then my Visa
expired and I had to go home oh you know
did you sell knives for a while I sold
Cutco Cutlery kitchen knives uh which is
also the year after 9 11 so a brown guy
at your door with knives
can I interest you with us
maybe don't start with the knife out at
that point but you have a like a demo
right so they give you leather strips
and then you cut the knife and then you
pile up the strips and then you cut the
pile of strips and you cut a penny in
half great knives and like a I think
it's like 135 dollar set at that time
and you make like 40 bucks commission
I've made zero sales you made no sales
after 9 11 no chance
um were you doing comedy right after 9
11. I was I was doing like rooms on the
south side of Chicago and what was that
like I was booed off stage seven weeks
in a row at a bar called Mike's is that
because I mean before they would even
listen to you yeah just like I mean it's
outside room in Chicago is always a
tough room right and very little
patience so I was just going up like
what's up with cockroaches or whatever
and they were like off
um and then I we do want to know what's
up with God
I think well coming to Netflix
The Secret Life of cockroaches now um
and then I think
the first joke I wrote was alliteration
and not very good but I just remember
kind of yelling at people because I was
just broke and frustrated and I was like
you know you Americans you don't value
Indian people we uh teach you in
colleges and we drive your taxis and we
are your gynecologists and we sell you
food without Indians you'd be starving
stranded sexless sterile and stupid uh
and that was the first laugh I got from
like a group of people oh that's so in a
way I mean when did you start to see
um
and this presupposes you saw it change
but things soften you know in the time
after 9 11.
I I I was gone by then you know but by
the time because your Visa expired my
Visa expired I went home and I wanted to
get into you know Bollywood and um
I got a job at CNBC which was the
craziest thing like I love John Stewart
I was a gigantic fan right and I ended
up taking a handicam what sorry before
that I went to Mumbai to be a VJ I don't
know if you guys know what a VJ is we
know what a VJ is yeah so it's just me
with like spiky hair and like no sleeves
and then well you're there
that's all you need Mikey hair necklace
yeah yeah and at some point a producer
actually told somebody else that like
his arms are too saggy so we're gonna
give him fake tattoos to cover up the
arms and I was like just give me sleeves
uh it would be easier if you just gave
me sleeves
this is why I've never you can't find
one picture of me sleeveless it's my
first rule I will have sleeves so now I
have henna tattoos that I have to like
to touch up every eight weeks
um and I was fired in like three months
and then I shot a pilot on my friend's
kitchen table which which is like a news
comedy pilot right and CNBC picked me up
and I got to go on the Prime Time news
at the end of The Primetime News
Bulletin at 9 45 into three minutes of
jokes every day and I was 26 you know on
a show that the prime minister is
watching and and that every major
businessman is watching and everybody
was kind of cool and patient to say this
is clearly a kid and he's clearly very
green but let's give him time and so I
got to do that for like four years
before trying to do film you know it's
interesting so you're you knew you were
funny and that you had this talent but
uh acting seemed to be something that
you were more interested in at the time
yeah for sure I uh this movie called
rang de basanti which is a Bollywood
Ensemble movie and you know Hindi movies
you know are full of beautiful people
just you know blessed by God beautiful
and talented and amazing and I just kind
of knew this isn't a space for me I'm I
won't cut it then I saw this movie that
had this lovely Ensemble with like three
other guys that looked like me and you
know now in India there's a path for
like an Adam's Handler kind of an actor
or Ben's still a kind of an actor right
then there wasn't and then I'm like I I
finally feel like there's a place for me
in the film industry and then I went to
an audition line it was a bunch of six
foot you know two guys who looked
amazing
so I I ended up shooting a stand-up
special with my own money and getting a
DVD together just making sure that the
DVD looked packaged enough the way it
could belong next to I don't know
Magnolia or something in a DVD Library
yeah and it was called viragra uh which
because you know
puns are always fun and uh I ended up
going to every DVD library in Mumbai
where I knew filmmakers rented DVDs from
and just giving them 10 free copies
and that made its way to different
production houses and like got me
auditioned so I got to kind of shortcut
my way in but that's I mean that's
incredible uh gumption and and and it
really uh and that is I think a word
from your culture gumption yeah it's
ancient Sanskrit word
uh but
um that that shows a lot of Ingenuity
and uh and that's that's very impressive
that you would do that
and what you were you saw yourself as
okay I could do this I'd like to be in
I'd like to crack this Bollywood film
industry and you know it is amazing to
me I don't think I don't think most
people who haven't uh looked into it can
understand how massive those stars are
in India I mean if it's it's
bigger than you know we think oh
celebrities here are revered well the
most revered celebrity here is probably
you know disliked and liked almost in
equal measure with a few exceptions but
uh it's it's a whole other thing in
India I think in the Indian film
industry once you get to whoever these
top 10 uh you know just the stars of
stars
probably the least famous of them is
more famous than a Kardashian you know
it is the way that I would put it it's
it's an amazing level of
the respectful adulation and fame at the
same time and it's because
to me it represents
beautiful escapism you know uh
picture like in my family we had Sunday
mornings was the only time that the
entire family would go out together and
you know dad is tired from work and Mom
is tired from work and you sit down in
the movie theater and watch one
Bollywood movie and then go out for
lunch so it has to be beautiful and
large and magnanimous like if you show a
spotlight we're gonna kill ourselves
you don't want to see a movie where
people in chinos are in a fluorescently
lit Newsroom talking about child abuse
no no no that's not going to get the
whole family you know it's very hard to
turn that into a musical
um
I tried I know I looked into it
Spotlight the musical hasn't happened I
tried I put a lot of my own money into
it and I'll just say it was a mistake